what's up everybody we're back in the
desert so today I wanted to show you how
we made our Saguaro shower we feel
really lucky to have so many beautiful
Saguaro Giants on this land when the
green Parts rot away at the end of their
life what remains are these Cactus bones
sometimes they fall to the ground but
sometimes they remain standing this was
the inspiration for our shower we
started by cementing a 4x4 pressure
treated Post in the ground and then
wrapping Saguaro bones around it we
screwed little bits here and little bits
there until the whole thing was covered
in Saguaro bones and we couldn't see the
post inside then we ran half inch copper
pipe up to a stainless steel shower
valve and fixture we place this big flat
stone at the base and also built a trail
that goes to and from the cabin the
desert is so healthy around the base of
the shower because of the runoff so we
planted a palm tree finally we used more
Saguaro bones to camouflage the
on-demand propane water heater that's
that my favorite place in the whole
world to take a shower and it's even
better at sunset